네, 안녕하세요. 빌사입니다. 오늘은
제가 공인 중계사에 대해서 좀 얘기를
해 보려고 하는데 얼마 전에 기사를
봤어요. 폐업률이 최대치로 올라갔고
그리고 개혁 공인 중계사 수가 계속
줄어들고 있다라는 기사입니다. 그래서
이걸 가지고 제가 좀 생각을 해
봤는데 일단은 지금 현재 공인중개사
시장이 좀 어떻고 지금 처에 있는
그런 위험 요소라든지 아니면은
실제로이 중개사님들이 수익이 어느
정도 되는지 그리고 앞으로 전망에
대해서 오늘 좀 영상을 찍어 보려고
합니다. 어, 우선은 자격증을 가진
사람이 전국에 한 55만 명 정도
있어요. 개업 공인중개사 수가 불과
몇 년 전만 해도 한 12만 명,
13만 명 [음악] 뭐 그 정도
수준이 되는데 최근에는 10만 명대로
떨어졌다라고 합니다. 그래서 그
정도로 폐업을 굉장히 좀 많이 했고
오히려 신규보다 폐업률이 더 높아요.
지금 공인 중개사 사무소 자체가 좀
좋지 않습니다. 올해 이번에 공인
중개사 시험이 끝났는데 어 중계사
응시율도 되게 떨어졌어요. 지금
합격자를 보더라도 지금 [음악] 역대
최저로 사람들의 관심도도 많이
떨어졌습니다. 그 이유 중에 하나가
가장 큰게 부동산이 불황이죠.
잘되는데만 되고 그리고 지금 워낙 그
규제가 많기 때문에 매매 거래는 좀
많이 없어요. 매매 거래는 많이 없고
대부분 다 이제 전월세 시장이 많은데
일단 전체적으로 거래 건수가 줄어서
지금 중개업 시장이 좀 좋지
않습니다. 그리고 시대적 변화도 되게
중요한 거 같아요. 그래서 뭐
직방이라든지 뭐 네이버
부동산들이라든지 이런 물건 정보를
쉽게 볼 수 있는 채널들이 많이
생기면서 중계사가 그냥 단순하게
짓보여 주고 일반적인 정보로 하기에는
뭐 쉽게 설명드리면 고객분들이 많이
똑똑해졌습니다. 그 시대 변화에 맞게
바꾸지 않는다면이 중개업 시장에서 좀
살아남기가 쉽지 않아요.이 중계
사무소 같은 경우에도 양극화가 되게
심해졌습니다. 잘되는 데는 굉장히
잘되고 안 되는 데는 계속 안 되고
있어요. 그 이유 중에 가장 큰게
이런 시대 변화와 맞춰서이 중계
사무소도 좀 다른 중계 사무소와 좀
다르게 어 운영을 해야 됩니다. 어
우선 첫 번째로 이제는 어 자리
좋은데 막 워킹님이 와 가지고 막
의뢰를 하는 그런 시즌 지났어요.
인터넷에 워낙 많은 정보가 공개돼
있기 때문에 일단 여러분들이 지금
중계 사무소를 한다라고 하면 첫
번째로 브랜딩이 돼야 됩니다. 그
동네하면 딱 떠올릴 만한 그런 중계
사무소가 돼야 되는데 대부분은 다 막
워킹님 그리고 광고만 올려놓고 한
명만 걸리면 어떻게 되겠지? 약간
이런 마인드로 일하는 경우가 많은데
지금 시대가 변하면서 브랜딩이 되지
않으면 어 살아남기가 쉽지 않습니다.
그리고 두 번째는 콘텐츠를 잘
만들어야 돼요. 예전에 했었던
수첩에다가 막 매물 정보 써 놓고
아니면 파워포인트에 막 이렇게 해
가지고 고객한테 그냥 이렇게 보여
주고 그게 아니라 예를 들어서 A라는
아파트를 내가 중계한다라고 하면 그
A라는 아파트의 콘텐츠를 내가 제일
많이 만들고 제일 유익하게 만들고
제일 알찬 그런 콘텐츠를 만들어야지
그걸 찾는 고객분들이 그 콘텐츠를
보고 많이 옵니다. 부동산 중계뿐만
아니라 콘텐츠를 잘 만들 줄 아셔야
돼요. 지금 그렇게 콘텐츠를 잘
만들지 않다라고 하면은이 시장에서
살아남기가 쉽지 않습니다. 여러분들이
여기서 어찌 됐든 살아남으려면
차별화가 있어야 됩니다. 뭐
고객분한테 일반적으로 하는 서비스들을
좀 바꿔보고 예를 들어서 뭐 내가
A라는 매물을 봤을 때 그거에 대한
정보 알아야 될 거 그리고 계약 전의
상황들 그런 것들을 깔끔하게 정리해서
고객한테 알림 서비스를 보낸다든지
아니면은 만기가 얼마 남지 않은
임차인들한테 미리 이제 사전에 만기
전에 해야 될 뭐 체크리스트를 막
이렇게 전달한다든지 이런 뭔가 다른
중계 사무소와 좀 차별화된 부분을 좀
하지 않으면 지금이 시장에서
살아남기가 쉽지 않습니다. 부동산은
제가 봤을 때 더 기업으로 바뀔 거
같아요. 더 기업화가 될 겁니다.
일본이나 미국처럼 이렇게 좀 기업화가
많이 될 거거든요. 평균적으로 월
매출 이거 제가 기사로 좀 찾아보니까
뭐 3천에서 4천만 원 정도 된다.
뭐 이런 기사를 좀 봤어요. 그래서
뭐 과반수 이상이한 그 정도 매출이
된다라고 하는데 근데 그 매출에서
사실 광고비 빼면은 거의 없어요.
거의 직장인 월급도 안 됩니다.
사무실 임대료 내고 뭐 광고비 내고
뭐 기타 사무용품 비용 내면은 진짜
월 뭐 200만 원 300만 원도 안
되거든요. 그 정도로 되게 어려운
중개사 사무소 사장님들이 되게
많아요. 이번에 공인 중개사 자격증
따신 분들도 굉장히 많으실 텐데 일단
자격증만 따면 다 사무소를 차릴 수
있어서 이런 부품 꿈을 가지고 차려
있는 경우가 되게 많은데 지금 부동산
중계 시장이 생각보다 되게 쉽지
않습니다. 저는 개업하기 전에 어디서
좀 뭐 일해 보는 것도 괜찮다라고
보거든요. 중계에서 공부할 땐 너무
좋았는데 내가 실제로 영업해 보고 막
하니까 내 성향이랑 안 맞을 수도
있거든요. 내 한번 일해 보고 내
성향이랑 맞는지 그리고 지금 내가
이걸로 해서 돈을 벌 수 있는지를
확인을 해 봐야 됩니다. 그래서 지금
같은 시기에는 정말 실력으로 그리고
남들과 차별화하지 않으면 지금
살아남기가 쉽지 않다라고 생각이
들어요. 정리해 보겠습니다. 아 저도
뭐 공인중계사지만 제가 4년 뒤면에
공인중개사 자격 증단지
20년이더라고요. 고인물입니다. 네.
그래서 제가 18살에 따 가지고 어
지금 16년째고 내년에 이제 17년
차인데 어 굉장히 진짜 한 눈물만
팠어요. 저는이 직업을 되게 좋아하고
중계사라는 직업이 좀 인정받지 못하는
직업이기도 합니다. 워낙 이제 좀 안
좋게 보는 시선도 있고데이
공인중개사라는 직업의 이식을 좀
바꿨으면 좋겠고 그리고 진짜 잘되고
열심히 하시는 분들이 좀 많이
생겨났으면 좋을 거 같아서 제가
이렇게 좀 영상을 찍게 됐고요.
그리고 이건 번 외인데 어
중계사님들의
뭔가 이런 연합을 만들까 지금 생각
중입니다. 만약에 혹시 관심 있으신
분 계시면 이메일로 좀 간단한
소개라든지 SNS 아이디라든지 이런
걸 좀 보내 주시면 제가 한 30명
정도 뽑아 가지고 간단하게 이렇게
모임도 하면서 좀 실력 있는
중계사님들을 잘 모아서이 중개업
시장을 좀 어떻게 바꾸면 좋을 건지
얘기를 나누는 그런 시간도 좀 만들면
좋을 거 같아요. 충분한 검증을
걸쳐서 제가 연락을 드리도록
하겠습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요. 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다.